hi there steve goffman here
um today i want to talk about
something that was trigger triggered by
a tweet that i saw because i followed it
from people on twitter and it has to do
with with um
reading and developing reading skills
developing language skills
and the realization that
learning languages even improving in our
own language
uh is what i would call a very warm and
fuzzy process
uh
so many things are involved emotional
things
and and therefore
sometimes the best intentioned
strategies on the part of teachers to
set specific goals to test people for
specific skills to teach specific skills
these things in fact are
counterproductive
so
what triggered this was an article that
again this is a gentleman that i follow
on twitter called daniel willingham or
willingham who writes on
education as an american
expert
and was one of the first people to
debunk
the sort of learning styles theory which
was all the rage for a while that some
people are
you know visual learners and
can kinetic learners or
oral learners and stuff
all of which is not true
and all of these things were taught to
teachers and stuff and essentially
that's not true we may have preferences
but we all learn the same way
and
and that is now increasingly accepted
anyway he has here uh a tweet which says
why american students haven't gotten
better at reading in the past 20 years
and i'm going to post a link to the
article in the description box and the
gist of it is that the reason they don't
is because the teachers try and teach
reading skills
and then test on these reading skills
when in fact the ability to read
is very much determined by how much
knowledge we have about the subject
and that if you let kids read widely on
things of interest to them
and if you have to test them which i
doubt but if you have to test them at
least test them on something that they
have been reading about
don't test their theoretical ability to
read
based on some
uh
content that is totally irrelevant to
them so there again it's a little bit
warm and fuzzy how do we improve in
reading we improve in reading by reading
more
uh but the general knowledge that we
have which we might have acquired
through reading which might have
acquired through experience from our
parents through spears it appears rather
that this or general level of knowledge
is going to influence how well we do
just as much as uh
any specific you know reading
instructional
uh strategies in the classroom and the
proof is that in the us american
students haven't gotten better at
reading and i often mention literacy
because it is a big issue there's still
a good 20 30 percent of the population
in most developed countries that have
trouble reading
well now how does this relate back to
language learning
you know i thought about this you know
my approach to arabic to greek to the
languages that i've been learning
recently is to jump right in listening
to stories
not worrying too much about specific
aspects of grammar occasionally checking
uh to see
some explanation of what i have already
experienced
uh
and so that uh you know again it's the
same idea i think one that i've said
this before one of the problems that
that i see with many language learners
is that they are too
methodical they want to master the
basics they're going to learn
the most important words first they're
going to set themselves deliberate goals
and so forth and i think this is largely
counterproductive we have in the case of
canada for example
uh
you know i saw a statistic that outside
of quebec 6.6 of the
english-speaking canadians
speak french 6.6
that's despite the fact that all of them
have 10 years however many years of
language instruction they are tested
every year they get tests during the
year they are taught specific rules of
grammar and at the end of the 10 years
they are incapable of speaking
and don't understand french so this
deliberate approach really for the vast
majority of those people doesn't work
because there are many fuzzy
elements that affect our ability ability
to learn i.e
our interest
our motivation
our opportunities to use the language so
there's all these other fuzzy things
and uh
you know
we have to
um
kind of
sometimes force ourselves into a
language in order to discover certain
things that we might get warm and fuzzy
about
and yes i do measure and we measure it
link how many words i know how many
words i've read
but all of these goals those are not so
much goals
that you know um
i sense that if i achieve this goal like
i have said when i get to 3000 words in
arabic known words i'm going to start
speaking
but really all of the things that we
measure words known words read and stuff
is mostly a measurement of our level of
activity
and the reason that i'm able to
you know increase my known words total
increase my number of words read is
because i have found content of interest
at least sufficient interest
all right right now my mini stories are
no longer very interesting to me but at
least it is content
what i have done with asimil where i
found it very difficult to go through
their book
i've actually had someone transcribe
these so that i can learn them at link
and now i'm actually quite motivated to
go through these stores where i at least
have a chance of of hearing the words
word for word reading them and so forth
and so on
but at the same time i've started to try
to pick my way through al jazeera where
there again there's content of interest
so i'm kind of moving back and forth
between
uh
easier content where i'm trying to
ingrain certain words and phrases and
more difficult content which is
challenging me
and as long as i find that that process
gives me a sense of satisfaction then
you know i'm not too too worried about
any specific goals
uh any specific
grammatical points anything that's very
you know
grounded in in you know master the
basics i just kind of want to enjoy the
process and if i enjoy the process and
i'm picking things up picking up words
picking up some bits of knowledge you
know one of the things we're going to do
with our with my arabic stories is i
have i'm in touch with people in
jordan and syria to get some 11
arabic versions of these stories done so
that i can at least understand how that
language you know those regional uh
versions of arabic work so it's just a
gradual process of involving involving
myself with the language
and so
you know to me language learning and i
think the most successful language
learners or maybe i shouldn't say that
maybe there are people who are very
deliberate step by step
uh learn the most frequent words first
and master the grammar first maybe those
people exist but i'm not that way
and i think for a lot of people and if
we refer back to this article about
reading
they have found that if you can make it
interesting for people if our people are
able to sort of gradually
you know accumulate some experience and
poke around and find things of interest
and they're given that freedom rather
than being tested
rather than being asked questions
rather than being taught to critically
think now even there for example these
teachers love to try to teach critical
thinking
critical thinking the ability to think
critically is based on relevant
knowledge if you have knowledge then you
can think critically there's no you know
uh objective ability to think critically
about a subject that you know nothing
about
so
language whether it be your own language
reading skills
or ability to use the language or
learning you know second third fourth
languages it is a fuzzy warm vague kind
of thing and we should push ourselves
forward
into things of interest and not
focus so much on trying to master
you know the first 10 chapters
but just move on and just let them let
the language wash over us
and in the end we'll be further ahead
so i don't know if this makes any sense
but uh that's kind of the what was
running through my mind after i saw that
tweet and i'll leave a
a link to that um article in the
description box oh and uh yeah one other
thing speaking of things being vague and
fuzzy is i spoke russian after the last
video and there were some people who
kindly pointed out that i had many
mistakes which i was also aware of after
i watched the video but i didn't
practice for it i just put it out there
and we can make mistakes and the more
we speak and if i were to be with
russian people for a week or two
speaking i start to pick up on it again
in sort of a warm and fuzzy process
maybe looking a few things up in a
grammar book but you do need that degree
of
again involvement in order to maintain a
certain level in your language but i
wanted to show just what it was after
essentially uh
no activity in russian for a couple of
years and that's what it is and i will
speak in another language at some point
but i've run a bit long today so i won't
be doing that today thanks for listening
[Music]
you